hey Robin says house next door to
y'all's for sale oh yeah it is is it
nice uh nice enough why are you thinking
about moving I wasn't but Robins not
crazy about living in a house I shared
with my ex-wife that's understandable I
want her to be happy cuz I love her
not just cuz she's a cop with a gun but
that's part of it well I'm sure there
are lots of wonderful houses out there
I'd be happy to help you look do you not
want us to look at the one next to you
oh no of course not you should
absolutely look at it as well as other
houses I have to say this isn't the
reaction I was expecting
no it is the reaction you were expecting
excited but boss might live next door to
me
yeah well my boss lives everywhere and
you don't see me getting weird about it
you
next Thursday young Sheldon's back with
a new episode the house next door to
mine is for sale I'm concerned about who
the new neighbor might be why don't you
just go out and find a buyer that you'd
be happy with
I wonder if statement Hawking would like
Texas it's very flat Joe salaz back with
a new episode next Thursday on CBS
[Music]